hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel today we're going to be showing
you how to program key for a 2019
jeep
cherokee
this is a push to start
we're going to be programming the key
using the
auto pro pad g2
you could use any
machine that you prefer
but in order to do so we want to bypass
the security gateway
used in uh
using this cable right over here
you can purchase this cable i believe
for a hundred dollars from uhs
now you want to go
down here
and you want to find this green
connector right here it's called this oh
we call it the star connector
so
let me pull it out and connect my cable
to it
all right now that we got the cable
connected to it
right there
we'll just go to the programmer
and start the programming procedure
all right it says then i need to connect
it to the internet
chrysler
automatically identify
okay it's 2019 yes
now i want to read pin
there's our pin
21 425
number of keys to
and
i'm gonna hold it near the center
console
and then continue to press the unlock
for that 10 seconds
hmm
all right
now
accepted our new key let's try to start
the vehicle
starts right up
that's it now just make sure you cut the
emergency key for the customer
good to go
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up
subscribe to the channel for more videos
you